welcome to this video round five of the
candidates and this video is about the
game coyoacán against mamedyarov we are
looking at the tournament situation of
both players they're both on- one
mamedyarov really started badly losing
two games in the early rounds but
bounced back a bit with a win against
and reagan good game good fighting game
kayaking on the other hand has not won a
game yet he lost to two Kramnik in an
interesting battle but never got close
to to winning a game so far so both
players really am young and actually
need a win somewhere to get back into
into the race and well let's see what
happens in this game kayaking playing
efore yeah he tried one see form for the
first time as he mentioned um yesterday
against Topalov but didn't really get
anywhere so he goes back to his normal
opening move one fo he also plays d4
from time to time but II for has been
his traditional first move okay
mamedyarov plays the sicilian and with
d6 probably signals his intention to
play a night off the most popular the
sodium after d6 has been played on gap
but Karacan no goes for Bishop b5 check
this has become yeah somewhat of a
fashionable line in in recent years and
yeah this i think has multiple reasons
one reason is that i think that like is
generally considered to be okay in the
main lines like in the night off and the
other thing is that with them yeah with
Magnus cards and being so successful
with them supposedly a non-critical
opening lines just delaying the fight
into the middle
game people are sort of looking for
lines where they just get a playable
position and maybe yeah prepare some
little thanks some little detail that
they can maybe try to get a game with a
little bit of something and then go from
there this is I think one reason why
this should be five check and has gained
some popularity it's also a move that
very often leads to positions were wide
it's not risking very much and we can
try something without losing very often
okay Mammadyarov plays Bishop d said
this is the soundest reply it's a bit
down but it's it's the sound of smooth
um if you want to fight us black gum
that's ninety seven and 96 obviously
there are only those those three moves I
personally have a liking for bishop for
knight c6 um um to what you get some
fight with castles and think we should
be 72 to go but there's also an ID seven
that can be it can be played to to just
keep the bishops down and keep it a bit
more complex okay Bishop d7 the sound is
smooth can't captures and play see form
yeah this that's the typical way to
proceed white sets up the blonde olma
Roxy bind with deform and we get exactly
that on the board so it's a Sicilian
type of position see against d point is
exchanged and the main thing here
compared to the roxy point in the
accelerated dragon is that the light
squared bishops i exchanged you could
argue that this favors wide as the light
squared Bishop normally only two is a
somewhat of a bad bishop because light
squares from light square pawns this is
true to some extent but also this
exchange is something that is not
unwelcome to black as well because he's
got somewhat of a space disadvantage and
very often you have this bishop on CA
and you don't really know where to put
it in the maroc seemed so um it's it's
sort of firm a neutral exchange you
cannot say it benefits on one player the
point here four wives that's central
office this color for white now is to
choose to choose a set up it's not so
set evident how wide should should
develop ki can now castle in a recent
game just a couple of days ago world
champion magnus carlsen played h3 in
this position against the peter hina
needs a strong GM from denmark and well
known for being the former chief second
of Russia anand and now he's one of the
trainers and seconds of cards and so
cars was playing against his some
straining partner they had this in a
rapid tournament in brazil and it was
quite interesting i will show you how
this game went bit later because it's so
it's more interesting to to see some
other idea for us to to make a
comparison um carry a complete castles
Mammadyarov as well yet here on now
kayaking plate be three if you would
have played h3 you would have transposed
to the Kazon nielsen game just another
move order what is important here that
the old moves the traditional move f3 a
move that for example i have played
myself on in some games at one point in
high my Chester endeavors I have
actually played before regularly and
went for this Bishop b5 check because I
didn't really want the mainline night
off and I always enjoyed the maroc
sabayon structure because you have a
nice space advantage yeah and this was
always thought to be slightly more
to provide until Iran shock introduce
this remarkable idea rook c8 attacking
this pawn b3 and now in 2003 he played
the amazing move d 5 which is just very
remarkable you break through on the
point where white has concentrated all
its forces and the the amazing point is
if let's let's start with the easy
things if white takes here yeah black
just wins the piece of course if white
takes with the night that's the movie 6
and what is White's move now the problem
is if you retreat here going to take
only four and just win the house or
hanging with check and we'll diagonal
here as as a disaster like just wins so
cannot take with the night but what
about pawn takes yeah now we see the
point of blacks play you can actually
sacrifice a PCM temporarily the LCD
again that's just good and easy for
black so night eggs and what now
obviously is six yeah black will get
them get the piece back and not even
it's not even possible for y2 to get a
pawn for it it's really amazing there
are few if you retreat it you will just
lose on the long diagonal even more
material so the best movie is in fact
Bishop h6 quite funny yeah this is check
the point of it so black will just
recapture here and now after take stakes
we will get a position where at best
white can count on equality um he does
not really have a great move in this
position this is the problem like is
threatening to take and if you can't
show yourself it's just like yeah
complete symmetry but those moves are
more our weakness they introduce
weaknesses on e3 and c3 and blankets
nicely centralized so this is even more
comfortable for black
to some extent nothing with which you
can win a game but it's it's quite okay
yeah um so what's the point of showing
all this it has a connection to the
cards and game against hina nielsen
where h3 was played and after root c8
and the skin needs and tried the same
idea the interesting point is now after
takes takes takes c6 Smith's pretty am
comparable but no Bishop h6 takes takes
takes white took on d525 and Knight f3
yeah and the big difference in this
position is there's a pawn on h3 and not
on f3 and this allows white to play
Knight f3 ok you can argue him isn't
this sad debt equal yeah it is not dead
equal it is Sir of course not like why
does just winning in brilliant attacking
fashion but there is some there's a
drawl of a poison into it um needs and
play droop da just to show how easy it
can can happen to get into trouble
Carlton exchange to play look T 1 and
now black you really must take check and
now we see that white is just better
developed 96 rooty 7 and even this is
not like winning four white but yeah
knowing Carson and his technical
abilities he managed to win the game and
yeah this is a nightmare position
against him I guess yeah group d 8 was
really a bad defense but those little
nuances like Age 3 instead of f3 they
are what makes this variation
interesting for white players to find
those little ideas that may be can like
can put some pressure on black it's not
like you will win then let's as
mentioned and a brilliant mating attack
but you maybe have some little things to
to play with ok I'm in this game there
was b3 plate
c6 we should be two and a six yeah enter
here there of course are many
possibilities why does not obliged to
play em like a Yaqui no dear deeply 95
white can also play em yeah
strengthening moves like Ruby one for
example or loop see one um well as cooks
you one day okay look see when I
sometimes there is this tactic but okay
why just just takes it yeah okay so what
can can improve with with rope moves I
can try to alter the structure and the
center in fact instead of the kayak in
snide d5 there was a recent game the
German Bundesliga between back row and
anish giri we're back row plate 96 26
yeah if you take with the pawn you
always have to reckon with those poor
mooses can be a bit annoying especially
considering that white also has this
move now well it took with the Queen and
then 95 was played I'm showing that
because this leads to a very similar
type of game and we've got in the game I
just think that this move order that
back row here went form is a bit more
precise and this in looks to me that
this is a small precise yeah here wider
threatening to damage the pawn structure
and threatening to take on his seven so
black gang took here on d5 ed Quincy
five and the capture and this is very
very similar as mentioned to the main
game I only think that this is a bit
more just slightly more comfortable for
white compared to the original game the
thing is that after rookie one there is
a temple here and white has little
things going for him if he plays Queen
d2 and rook c1 which she did in the game
there is the before idea we're using the
tempo on the Queen and this always
checks him to win an important temple
and this is not possible in the main
game I think this is a bit more precise
at least my my superficial impression
the back row actually want a nice game
here but I don't want to show the whole
game within this analyzes okay 95 was
played and we see that the structure is
it's identical to what I just shown but
now the queen is on d7 and I think it's
actually better on the 7th as it defends
here and it prepares a quick be five in
fact be fibers of course what normandy
isle of palladium we have a very basic
pawn structure now that quite often pops
up in the sicilian especially in the
maroc see point e seven of course is a
course of concern for black white will
pile up on this pond and this is a
somewhat annoying pressure the thing is
though we have quite number of pieces
exchanged already that favors black it's
helpful to have some exchanges already
done if you are in this kind of
situation where you have less space than
the opponent and black here rather
quickly has gained counter play on the
queenside will see that after rookie one
and can put those moves on the board
yeah h5 this is typical age for is
threatening h5 and black just blocks
this possibility we see that black has
counter play against the c-4 porn and
therefore it's not so easy for white to
make any of any substantial progress he
played very natural moves now kayaking
loopy for ya doubling on the e-file and
like doubled on the C file to get get
the counter play if in this position why
it now takes only seven we get this
type of position and in fact here it is
white who needs to be careful because
it's easily imaginable that black can
coordinate his rooks to to win the
spawns and it can be can be tricky note
that in the game and wrong before clay I
can also had Queen and pawn against no
kayaking at the two rooks actually in a
comparable situation now with topalov
but there the rooks couldn't really
coordinate which i think is possible
here rookie 7 is simply not not helping
right at all he played Queen to be 6
attacking this a pawn yeah and I think
now mama dro firm also could have taken
on c4 and it leads to very similar
positions to the game you played a file
first to gave away the spawn and now to
consi form yeah it's it's really am not
much happening to be honest right now if
he does not want to stand worse needs to
take only seven I mean this is just
better for black already those corns are
weak h4 was hanging so not helpful at
all you need to take his seven that's
just the natural way to go and now
manyara pledged qe2 f5 yeah so black has
lost upon his lost the Ricky 7 poem but
as a compensation he has gained some
activity the Queen has come out to f5
wet initiates some counter play yeah and
also on d5 and the rooks are ready to
get even more active on the second rank
um in this position I think black is
perfectly fine and he will always get
enough counter play to trade down to a
completely drawn endgame very often you
will just get the porn back um yeah
kayaking thought for some time I he
tried to try to do something but it sobs
I'm sorry
this was just too quick plate Queen d2
back and this basically agrees to the
draw offer but you don't you don't
really have anything anything great iam
when white can can hardly get any
activity going with black being so
active there's also just h4 forcibly
hanging that you need to be aware of if
Y play something like a four for example
trying to push the pawn like we'll just
take it and it's not clear what would
White's great compensation is for for
giving up the pond if you play g3 to
cover it there's this move coming and
something like this is not really wide
playing for an advantage it's a it's
already a bit uncomfortable to play this
position you should draw of course with
precise play but it's not playing for
win yeah he went Queen d2 and normandie
are critiquing Queen to F for the good
move it agrees to a queen trade but
simply leads to a position where black
is so active that you will get the porn
back he's attacking here and yeah of
course taking the Queen if he would have
taken on h4 we need to check that there
is green age six now Andrew p8 will win
for white so this was one simple thing
to to not go for but Queen affords
perfectly okay white now has a hard time
not to exchange Queens and when he did
after g3 h4 saying who got 5 black has
discount a plane and will win the pawn
if white tries to keep it there's also
this move first which provokes white
basically or forces wide to play a form
after Luke c5 you will get this back
anyway it's just not much happening here
kayaking went for this check here they
agreed to a draw yeah it's completely
dead black will probably just trade a
word the steeple
and then we have three against three on
one side of the board yes well this does
not have much content this game at least
I try to do it a little bit of a
theoretical overview of this of this
line maybe if you play this as wide you
can use this idea by carlsmith with h 3
which seems to be interesting at least
to get a little bit of something not a
big edge you cannot expect that but it's
it's at least far more challenging than
this f3 rook c8 which seems to simply
equal eyes so black yeah for both
players the draw is not it's not great
but they're also in a position where
they cannot afford an additional loss
and what i do think though that kayaking
is not yeah well it does not feel like
he's he's yeah i would expect a bit a
bit sharper play to be honest to to get
something but okay it's it's it's
difficult of course but 95 and all this
is it just trades too much pieces and
it's too little simply to to win a game
i mean if you look at this position here
exactly White has many possibilities to
keep at least some tension in the
position but 95 is just I think making
it relatively easy for black here to to
equalize yeah I hope you've enjoyed the
game anyway there was some additional
theoretical information at least thanks
for watching